>>> A STUNNING IMA COMING OUT
OAF A RUSSIAY
ON THEK.WET IDENTIFY WHEN THE TP
SANCTIONARE.RUSSIA IIN
HEN RUSS, TH
STS ONHE
BITE, ORDINARY PEOHAVE BEE
SNTHEY ARE JOSTLING WITH EACH
OTHER IN TTO BUY
GOOD BLESS YOU, THVOICSAYS,
AS THEY PUSH ALLEY O SHOPPERS.TS
E PULI.
ANPRN
YS T WE SE SEE
OUECONOMIC IMPACBE THE
SHORTAGE, IT'S A
MP-- MOST OF TAGES ARA TEMPORAR
E OD APPEAR.
ITN D
EVERYTS .
WITH TUALITY O
INCOME IS NOT  - THIS PROBLEM
CO ENGRAINED
IAN BRANDSD CR TFLOCKED TO AUPEF
PRODUCTIONO GO. TREA F L CT
FATHER W B CONDITION. EVERYS S
BACK, ANE HIM.
AN ECONOMIC DONG THEIR
NATION
ETAND
THE N TOWN. OF THE CHLE
LINOMIC RESTRUCTD
WE GOT OVER IT ALL, SHE SAYSNT
AIE OUT
ED T
SAY,ANIOAMAGINTH
HAN' WORKED G SS
CHANGES THLIN'S POLICY.
ANTH WILL FOKRHANGCOURSE?
>> HONES DOUBTT.
C OF THE
CURESSIA.
PRESSURE.AKES HIM ME PEIS.
>> ECONO, IS AE THE KREMLI TO
>> Reporter: T IS O KE PRE
ITS ECONOMY FROM
FORCES UNFRIENDLS TOY FOR GAUS